It's 1925 in Syracuse, New York, and a young man is going into the Park Brannock shoe store on South Salina Street, and he's about to encounter what I think truly is the greatest gadget in American history. He's going to have his shoe size measured in this newfangled metal gadget that measures the length of your foot and the width of your foot and most crucially the arch length of your foot. foot and that's the length from your heel to the ball of your foot. This arch length measurement is a brand new concept in 1925. It might seem unnecessary, but actually, it's really important. Two people can have the same heel to toe measurement, but a different arch measurement. And so they might need different size shoes or have the width adjusted slightly. And this measurement is so your shoes are going to fit better and your shoes aren't going to
那是1925年的纽约锡拉丘兹，一个年轻人走进了南萨利纳街的帕克·布兰诺克鞋店，他即将遇到我认为可以说是美国历史上最伟大的小发明。他将在一款新奇的金属小工具上测量鞋码，这个小工具可以测量你的脚长、脚宽，最关键的是还能测量你的足弓长度。足弓长度就是从你的脚后跟到脚掌球部的距离。在1925年，测量足弓长度是一个全新的概念。这看起来似乎没有必要，但实际上它非常重要。两个人的脚后跟到脚趾的尺寸可能相同，但足弓尺寸却不同。因此，他们可能需要不同尺码的鞋，或者需要稍微调整鞋宽。进行这项测量的目的是让你的鞋子更合脚，而且你的鞋子不会
wear out as much because you're going to be walking in them more smoothly. And nothing like that had ever been devised before. And it basically revolutionized shoe size fitting. So this metal thing that measures the length and width and arch of a foot, it has a name. What is this thing called? It's called a Branick device. The Branick device. You probably stepped into one of these at some point in your life. Most likely when you were a child. I remember going to the shoe store when I was a kid. And of course, I was excited to get a new pair of shoes, but I was maybe more excited at the opportunity to use the brandic device. I love the cool touch of the metal, the slide of the knobs, the sturdiness of the device. It was a pleasing experience.
磨损得那么厉害，因为你穿着它们走路时会更顺畅。此前从来没有发明过类似的东西。它基本上彻底革新了鞋码的测量方式。所以这个能测量脚的长度、宽度和足弓的金属玩意儿有个名字。这东西叫什么？它叫布兰诺克测量仪。布兰诺克测量仪。你这辈子大概在某个时候也踩进过其中一个里面。多半是在你还是个孩子的时候。我记得小时候去鞋店买鞋。当然，我对能买一双新鞋感到兴奋，但比起这个，我可能更兴奋于有机会使用布兰诺克测量仪。我喜欢金属那冰凉的触感、旋钮的滑动感、装置的坚固性。那是一段令人愉快的经历。
And it stayed with me. I can tell you, for me, it definitely made an impression when I was a kid. And I'm pretty sure from having talked to a lot of people. I think that is a common memory that people have, that it's a nostalgic fun memory of going to the shoe store and also that this object, this device, seemed very specialized and official and you felt like you were in this adult world as a child. Yeah. You were taken seriously. Like in a way, you were kind of cared for. Yes. It seems very professional, very official. And the brandic device really is good for only one thing, but it's the perfect example of that thing, right, in terms of
而且它一直留在我的记忆中。我可以说，对我而言，它在我小时候确实留下了深刻的印象。而且我很确信，在和许多人交谈过后，我认为这是人们共同的记忆，那是去鞋店时一种怀旧而有趣的记忆，而且这个物品、这个装置显得非常专业和正式，当你还是个孩子时，你会觉得自己仿佛身处成人的世界。是的。你受到了认真的对待。某种程度上，你受到了关爱。是的。它看起来非常专业，非常正式。布兰诺克测量仪其实只能用来做一件事，但它堪称那件事的完美典范，对吧，在
measuring the foot. So it's this singularly focused product. Similarly, Charles Brannick was a very singularly focused guy. He named his invention after himself, the Brannock device, then founded a company to manufacture it that he named after the device, the Brannick device company. And he never invented anything else. But it's not just the device or the inventor that draws me to this object. Over the last 100 years, the American financial system has, has become increasingly complicated and opaque. Companies are designed to benefit shareholders, not consumers or workers. And the average person doesn't really understand how all the money flows.
测量脚部方面。所以这是一个极度专注的产品。同样，查尔斯·布兰诺克也是一个非常专注的人。他以自己的名字为自己的发明命名——布兰诺克测量仪，接着创立了一家公司来制造它，并以该装置的名字将其命名为布兰诺克测量仪公司。而且他再也没有发明过其他任何东西。但吸引我关注这个物品的，不仅仅是这个装置或发明家。在过去的一百年里，美国的金融系统变得日益复杂和不透明。公司的设计初衷是为了让股东受益，而不是为了消费者或工人。而普通人并不真正理解所有的资金是如何流动的。
Compare that to the brandic device and its simple business model, which remains almost unchanged for a century. The brand device has no brand extensions, as they would say now. And there's no venture capital. You know, it's a very simple operation. And people can wrap their head around that, and there's something satisfying about that. From 99% Invisible and BBC Studios, this is a history of the United States in 100 Objects.
相比之下，布兰诺克测量仪及其简单的商业模式在一个世纪里几乎保持不变。正如现在人们所说的那样，布兰诺克测量仪没有品牌延伸。也没有风险投资。你知道，这是一种非常简单的运作方式。人们能够理解这一点，这其中有一种令人满足的感觉。来自“99%隐形”和BBC工作室，这里是“100件物品中的美国史”。
I'm Roman Mars. Today, the Branick device, a perfect device in an imperfect world. How this object came to be, how it has endured, and just how much business in America has changed. I've wanted to tell the story of, why the brandic device is so pleasing for a very long time. And when I decided to do it, there was only one person I could call. My name is Paul Lucas and I'm a journalist and I specialize in writing about things that other people either don't notice or take for granted.
我是罗曼·马斯。今天的主角是布兰诺克测量仪，一个不完美世界中的完美装置。这个物品是如何诞生的，它是如何延续至今的，以及美国的商业已经发生了多么巨大的变化。我一直想讲述为什么布兰诺克测量仪如此令人愉悦的故事，这个愿望已经持续了很长时间。而当我决定做这件事时，我只能打电话给一个人。我叫保罗·卢卡斯，我是一名记者，专长于撰写那些被其他人忽视或视为理所当然的事物。
Paul published an all-time great zine on these types of objects back in the 90s called Beerframe. He also runs a blog devoted to the minutia of sports uniforms called UniWatch. Today, he writes a newsletter on Substack called Inconspicuous Consumption. And a brandic device has always seemed to me to be prototypically, classically inconspicuous. Pretty much everyone knows what it is. I think it's fair to say there's probably nobody listening to this podcast episode right now whose foot has not been in a brannic device at some point. It's pretty much a universal touchstone in our culture.
保罗在90年代曾出版过一本关于这类物品的史诗级同人杂志，名叫《Beerframe》。他还运营着一个专注于运动制服细节的博客，名叫“UniWatch”。如今，他在Substack上撰写一份名为《低调消费》的通讯。而布兰诺克测量仪在我看来一直都是原型般、经典般低调的存在。几乎每个人都知道它是什么。我觉得可以这样说，此时此刻收听这个播客节目的听众里，大概没有人没把脚塞进过布兰诺克测量仪里。它可以说是我们文化中的一个全民通用基准。
And yet nobody knows what it's called or almost nobody. So that means it is simultaneously ubiquitous and anonymous. Paul's obsession with the brannic device began in 1992 when he read an obituary for the inventor. That was the first time he connected a name to the object, and it happened around the same time he was developing his beat. It was sort of a perfect confluence of an impulse I had with the ultimate example of that impulse. Because I've never come across anything else that really can supplant the brannic device. as my North Star. And over the years, I've written a lot about it.
然而却没有人知道它叫什么名字，或者几乎没有人。这意味着它既无处不在又默默无名。保罗对布兰诺克测量仪的痴迷始于1992年，当时他读到了这位发明家的一则讣告。那是他第一次将一个名字与这个物品联系起来，而这正好发生在他开始建立自己的报道领域的同一时期。这某种程度上完美契合了我内心的某种冲动，它正是这种冲动的终极范例。因为我从未遇到过其他任何真正能取代布兰诺克测量仪的东西，它成为了我的北极星。这些年来，我写了很多关于它的文章。
I even have a tattoo of it, which I realize may seem like a bit much. But it's my ultimate object. The inventor's name was Charles Branach. He was born in 1903 in Syracuse, New York. Charles Brannick had shoes and shoe sales in his blood, you might say. His father co-owned the Park Brannock shoe store, the one from the beginning of the store. Charles worked there while he was in high school. It occurred to him that there was a need for better shoe sizing, that a lot of people complained that their shoes didn't fit properly or they were uncomfortable.
我甚至还纹了一个它的纹身，我意识到这可能显得有点过头了。但它是我心中的终极物品。这位发明的名字叫查尔斯·布兰诺克。他于1903年出生在纽约州锡拉丘兹。你可以说，查尔斯·布兰诺克的血液里流淌着鞋履和卖鞋的基因。他的父亲是帕克·布兰诺克鞋店的合伙人，也就是故事开头提到的那家店。查尔斯在读高中时就在那里工作。他意识到市场需要更好的鞋码测量方式，因为许多人抱怨他们的鞋子不合脚或者穿起来很不舒服。
The other devices at the time were just glorified yardsticks that measured only length, or just length and width, if you turned it sideways. Nothing measured that critical dimension of arch length. And so while he was in college in his early 20s at Syracuse University, he sort of had an impulse to try to create such a device. And his college roommate would recall that he would wake up in the middle of the night, two or three in the morning. And there was Charlie Brannick sitting at a desk with the light on, scribbling notes and making drawings. And his roommate would say, what are you doing? You're keeping me up at night.
当时的其他设备只不过是被美化了的标尺，只能测量长度，或者如果你把它侧过来，也只能测量长和宽。没有任何设备能测量足弓长度这个至关重要的维度。因此，当他在20出头、就读于锡拉丘兹大学的大学期间，他萌生了一种尝试创造这样一种装置的冲动。他的大学室友回忆说，他会在半夜醒来，比如凌晨两三点。而查理·布兰诺克正坐在开着灯的桌子旁，涂涂画画地做笔记。他的室友会说：“你在干嘛？你吵得我没法睡觉。”
And Charlie would say, you know, I had an idea for the invention. I'm working on this thing. And I have to write it down or I might forget. So that thing that comes up with, the brandic device, could you describe it? You have one next to you. Of course, you do. So it's a metal object. It has two sort of cupped areas, one at each end. And that's so you can put your heel to measure one foot in this sort of cupped receptacle,
而查理会说：“你知道的，我有一个关于发明的想法。我正在研究这个东西。我必须把它写下来，否则我可能会忘掉。”所以，他发明出来的那个东西，也就是布兰诺克测量仪，你能描述一下它吗？你身边就有一个。当然，你肯定有。所以它是一个金属物体。它有两个类似杯状的区域，两端各有一个。这样你就可以把脚后跟放进这个杯状的凹槽里来测量一只脚，
and then turn the brandic device around to do the other foot. It has one sliding piece that moves backward and forward to measure the width of your foot. And then it has another slide. piece to measure your arch length. And then it has yet another sliding piece for the length of your foot. So it's metal. The one I'm holding is made of aluminum, which has been the case for decades now. They've been made out of aluminum. I believe the early ones were made of steel. And it feels solid, but not too heavy. And I don't know how else to say this. It just looks like it knows what it's doing. It looks so, it looks so official and professional and it has so many calibrations and numbers on it.
然后转动布兰诺克测量仪来测量另一只脚。它有一个可以前后移动的滑动部件，用来测量你的脚宽。然后它还有另一个滑动部件来测量你的足弓长度。接着它还有一个滑动部件，用来测量你的脚长。所以它是金属的。我手里拿的這個是用铝制成的，几十年来一直如此。它们都是用铝做的。我相信早期的产品是用钢做的。它摸起来很结实，但又不会太重。我不知道该怎么表达。它看起来就像知道自己在做什么。它看起来是那么正式、那么专业，上面有那么多的刻度和数字。
I mean, that could just be nonsense, right? You could just put a lot of ruled lines and numerals on things and just make it seem like, like, you know, a thermometer or a barometer or something like that. But it, it has this feel of a finely tuned, finely calibrated instrument. And it is. It's hard to pin down the exact birth date of the brand of the project of. But Paul says an early version was definitely in use by 1925. And again, that was really the point. Charles Brannick invented this not to be an industry tool, but to give his family's shoe store competitive sales advantage. But other stores did take notice.
我的意思是，那可能只是一些无意义的符号，对吧？你完全可以在东西上画满刻度线和数字，让它看起来像个温度计、气压计或诸如此类的东西。但它确实给人一种微调精准、校准精细的仪器的感觉。事实也的确如此。很难确定布兰诺克项目确切的诞生日期。但保罗说，早期版本在1925年时肯定已经投入使用了。再说一次，这才是重点。查尔斯·布兰诺克发明这个东西并不是为了把它作为行业工具，而是为了给家族的鞋店带来竞争优势。但其他鞋店确实注意到了这一点。
And soon there was demand from other outlets, not just in Syracuse, but out of town, around the country. So Brannick filed a patent that wouldn't be granted until 1920. But in the meantime, he got busy. He initially thought he would just need a handful of prototypes to use at his family's store. But now that there was a demand, he needed to create a company. And so he launched the Brannock device company in Syracuse to manufacture these things. It's almost a quaint idea of how invention works. Charles Brannick saw a need.
很快，来自其他地方的需求也出现了，不仅在锡拉丘兹，还有外地以及全国各地。于是布兰诺克申请了一项专利，直到1920年才获批。但在那期间，他忙碌了起来。他最初以为自己只需要几个原型在家族的鞋店里使用。但既然现在有了需求，他就需要创办一家公司。于是他在锡拉丘兹创立了布兰诺克测量仪公司来制造这些东西。这几乎是一个关于发明如何运作的古朴构想。查尔斯·布兰诺克看到了需求，
He made a thing and people wanted it. So Brannick manufactured more and sold them to people who needed them. And as demand grew, the Brannock company grew with it. Well, let's put it this way. If it was launched in Syracuse in 2025, by 1929, international sales were starting. Okay? So not just around the country, but around the world, or at least across the ocean in Europe. So that's a pretty big deal.
他制造了一个东西，人们想要它。于是布兰诺克制造了更多，并把它们卖给需要的人。随着需求的增长，布兰诺克公司也随之壮大。好吧，我们这么说吧：如果它是在2025年于锡拉丘兹推出的，那么到1929年，国际销售就已经开始了。好吧？不仅在全国各地，而且在世界各地，或者至少跨越大洋远销欧洲。所以这是一件相当了不起的大事。
Charles Brannick developed a junior model because kids' feet are not just smaller than adult feet. They're proportioned differently. Brannick took his role in shoe fitting very seriously. He had this quote early in his Brannick career where he said, The shoe salesman, like a doctor, has a distinct responsibility to his customers. A mistake in the fitting of a shoe, particularly a child's, can easily endanger a person's health. The misfitted feat of today are the crippled feet of tomorrow. The junior model came out in 1933, and that same year, Brannick got his big break.
查尔斯·布兰诺克开发了一款青少年型号，因为小孩子的脚不仅比成人的脚小，而且比例也不同。布兰诺克非常认真地对待自己在鞋码测量方面所扮演的角色。在他的布兰诺克生涯早期，他曾说过这样一段话：“鞋类销售员就像医生一样，对他的顾客负有明确的责任。鞋子尺码不合适，尤其是小孩子的鞋，很容易危及一个人的健康。今天脚没穿好鞋，明天就会变成畸形足。”青少年型号于1933年问世，同年，布兰诺克迎来了他的重大突破。
A United States Navy ships captain noticed that, his sailors were complaining a lot of ill-fitting shoes. So he knew of the brannock device. It's not clear if he was from Syracuse or, you know, if he had just encountered it at another shoe store. And he had his sailors when they were docked somewhere refitted with a brannock device. And he was so happy with the results because his sailors were no longer complaining that he wrote an article in the July 1933 issue of a publication called United States Naval Institute Proceedings. where he described how the brannock device had eliminated foot troubles aboard his ship. Charles Brannick heard about the article, and Evered the believer in his own invention, he sent copies of it to important people around the armed forces.
一名美国海军舰长注意到，他的水手们经常抱怨鞋子很不合脚。因此他知道了布兰诺克测量仪。目前还不清楚他是来自锡拉丘兹，还是在另一家鞋店偶然见过这东西。当他的水手们在某个地方靠岸时，他让他们用布兰诺克测量仪重新测量了脚码。他对测量结果非常满意，因为水手们不再抱怨了，于是他在1933年7月出版的一本名为《美国海军学会会刊》的刊物上发表了一篇文章，在文中他描述了布兰诺克测量仪是如何消除他船上水手们的足部烦恼的。查尔斯·布兰诺克听说了这篇文章，作为自己发明的坚定信仰者，他将文章的复印件寄给了军队里的重要人物。
Pretty soon, most branches of the U.S. military were using brannock devices to outfit their service members. Then, on December 7, 1941, Japan attacked Pearl Harbor, and the U.S. entered World War II. Suddenly there's a huge demand because there's a huge surge in enlistment in the U.S. armed forces and the military wants brannock devices because they need to fit all these people. And brannock makes a modification. Instead of the single brannock device, which you turn around to measure each foot, you know, you put your heel in one end to do the right foot and the other end for the left foot, he comes up with a double brannock device, which is sort of two brannock devices mounted on a board. And I actually have one of these that was made for the Air Force. And the idea is that if you have all these new enlistees and they're sort of marching through getting fitted for uniforms and you're giving them their crew cut and all that, you know, so that they could, you know, go off to war, you can't waste time turning the device around. Of course not. And so you have this double brannock device so that they can have both feet measured simultaneously. And it's more efficient. It's
很快，美国军队的大多数分支都开始使用布兰诺克测量仪来为他们的军人配发鞋履。接着，在1941年12月7日，日本袭击了珍珠港，美国卷入了第二次世界大战。突然之间，需求量暴增，因为美国武装部队的入伍人数急剧飙升，军方需要布兰诺克测量仪来为所有人测量尺码。于是布兰诺克做出了改进。他没有采用需要转来转去测量每只脚的单头布兰诺克测量仪（你知道的，把脚后跟放在一端测右脚，另一端测左脚），而是发明了双头布兰诺克测量仪，这基本上是把两个布兰诺克测量仪安装在了一块木板上。我实际上就有一个为空军制造的这种设备。这个设计理念是，如果你有这么多新入伍的士兵，他们排着队来测量尺码以领取制服，还要剪平头等等诸如此类的事情，为了让他们能赶赴战场，你不能把时间浪费在把测量仪转来转去上。当然不能。所以你有了这个双头布兰诺克测量仪，这样就可以同时测量他们的两只脚。它更高效，
faster. I mean, there's a funny, there's like an old, I don't know, where this comes from some general that says like an army marches on his stomach, like meaning that you have to keep the troops well fed. But the truth is, is that armies march on their feet. Yeah, like your boots and your shoes. It's a big deal. And I like to say that's how Charles Brennick helped defeat fascism.
更快。我的意思是，有一个有趣的说法，不知道是从哪里传出来的，某个将军曾说过“军队是靠肚子行军的”，意思是必须让军队吃饱饭。但事实是，军队是靠双脚行军的。是的，就像你的靴子和鞋子。这可是一件大事。我喜欢说，这就是查尔斯·布兰诺克帮助战胜法西斯的方式。
You know, it's in like, it's literally true. He had a role in U.S. military preparedness and the call to action. The Brannock device of today is very close to the one Charles Brannick introduced in his father's shoe store in the mid-1920s. He did make small refinements over the years, but nothing major. And he didn't really need to make many changes because the Brannock device was what we would now call a category killer. You know, that term didn't exist back in his day. But it essentially wiped out the competition. Nobody ever seriously challenged it.
你知道的，这在某种程度上是字面意义上的真实。他在美军的战备状态和总动员中发挥了作用。如今的布兰诺克测量仪与查尔斯·布兰诺克在20世纪20年代中期在他父亲的鞋店里引入的那款非常相似。这些年来他确实做了一些微小的改进，但没有什么重大改变。而且他真的不需要做出太多改变，因为布兰诺克测量仪就是我们现在所说的“品类杀手”。你知道的，在他那个年代还没有这个词。但它基本上消灭了竞争对手。从来没有人真正对它构成过严肃的挑战。
and it really was and still is the gold standard. There are brandic device copycats out there. The patent expired decades ago, so there's nothing the company can do. These imitations are made abroad in places where materials and labor are cheaper. But they're also made more cheaply. If you were at a shoe store and saw a knockoff brannic, especially if it was more than a few years old, you could see the difference in terms of like the fixtures and the fittings
它过去是，现在依然是黄金标准。市面上确实有布兰诺克测量仪的仿冒品。专利几十年前就已经过期了，所以公司也无可奈何。这些仿制品产自海外材料和劳动力更便宜的地方。但它们的做工也更低劣。如果你去鞋店看到一个山寨版的布兰诺克测量仪，特别是如果它已经用了好几年，你就能看出区别，比如它的固定件和配件
just aren't as nicely calibrated. It's not as well made. Charles Brannick died in 1992 at the age of 89. He was a lifelong bachelor, married only to his invention, and he never invented anything else. It's really interesting to me. So many inventors, you know, they get the bug to invent something, and they just keep going. Charles Brannick kind of nailed it on the first shot. He was only in his 20s, his early 20s.
根本没有那么精致的校准。它没那么精工细作。查尔斯·布兰诺克于1992年去世，享年89岁。他终身未婚，只与他的发明结为连理，再也没有发明过其他东西。这让我觉得非常有趣。许多发明家，你知道的，他们一旦有了发明的狂热，就会一直搞下去。查尔斯·布兰诺克却在第一次出手时就大获成功。他当时只有20多岁，刚出头。
And it was one and done. Brennick had no children and no succession plan. But keeping in line with their founder's values, the company made a very unusual decision about how to move forward. They set a fixed price for the sale of the company, and they asked potential buyers to make their case. One requirement was that the new owner had a promise to keep manufacturing in Syracuse for at least five years. It was almost like a job application. Like, who is worthy to become the steward of this iconic American product? American manufacturing had been on the decline since the 1980s, so this requirement wasn't just unusual.
而且是一击即中，干完收工。布兰诺克没有孩子，也没有接班人计划。但为了契合他们创始人的价值观，公司就如何继续前进做出了一项非常不寻常的决定。他们为公司的出售设定了一个固定的价格，并要求潜在的买家陈述理由。其中一个要求是，新业主必须承诺在锡拉丘兹继续制造至少五年。这几乎就像是一场求职面试。就像是：谁才配成为这个标志性美国产品的守护者？自20世纪80年代以来，美国的制造业一直在走下坡路，所以这个要求不仅不同寻常，
It was making a statement. The brand device company was saying that a sustainable American-made product is still possible. And the plan worked. Half a dozen people applied to buy the company, most of them from the shoe industry. But there was this one guy named Salvador Leonardi. He was in manufacturing in upstate New York. He had a family company that was founded by his father in, the 1940s, they were arguably even more specialized than the brand of device. They made these
而且是在表明一种态度。布兰诺克测量仪公司在宣告：一个可持续的美国制造产品依然是可能的。而这个计划成功了。有六个人申请收购该公司，其中大多数来自鞋业。但有一个名叫萨尔瓦多·莱奥纳尔迪的家伙。他在纽约州北部从事制造业。他有一家家族企业，由他的父亲在20世纪40年代创立，他们的业务可以说比布兰诺克测量仪还要专业。他们制造
metal frames for purses and handbags. Like if you can imagine how a handbag opens and closes the sort of metal frame around the flaps, that's what they made. Like a clutch purse style. That's really satisfying snap when it comes together like a clamshell. Exactly. Exactly. But Sal Leonardi wanted to go into business for himself, sort of have his own. business, something that he could call his own. And he thought, oh, this, you know, this is the perfect thing I can do. Sal Leonardi eventually passed the company down to his son-in-law, Tim Follett. And both men really seem to embody what makes the brandic device special. They are very low-key, kind of not flashy people. And I don't mean that in a negative way. On the contrary,
钱包和手提包的金属框。如果你能想象手提包是如何开合的，也就是翻盖周围的那种金属框，那就是他们制造的东西。就像手拿包的款式那种。当它像蛤蜊壳一样合上时，会有那种非常令人满足的“啪”的一声。完全正确。完全正确。但萨尔·莱奥纳尔迪想要自己创业，拥有属于自己的生意，做一些他可以真正称之为属于自己的东西。他心想，哦，这个，你知道的，这就是我能做的完美的事情。萨尔·莱奥纳尔迪最终将公司传给了他的女婿蒂姆·福利特。这两个人似乎都真正体现了使布兰诺克测量仪与众不同的特质。他们非常低调，不是那种张扬的人。我这不是在贬义上说的。相反，
they really believe that if you make a quality product, it speaks for itself. And I've I've interviewed them and known them for a while now, and they believe strongly in the idea of you make it better, not faster. You use good materials. You hire good people. And they are not sort of publicity seekers. And I think there's a lot to be said for that. It seems almost inconceivable in today's marketplace of influencers and social media and all the rest where everything is hype, hype. and the attention economy and all of that.
他们坚信，如果你制造出优质的产品，它自然不言自明。我采访过他们，认识他们也有一段时间了，他们坚信“要做得更好，而不是更快”的理念。你使用优质的材料。你雇佣优秀的人才。而且他们不怎么追逐名利。我认为这很说明问题。在当今这个充斥着网红、社交媒体以及各种喧嚣的市场上，一切都是炒作、炒作、注意力经济等等，这几乎是不可想象的。
That is not how the Brannock device has been promoted. Yeah, yeah. I mean, it's captured your attention, certainly, but it has not captured it. The Brank device has captured my attention, too. And there's one story about the Brank Device company that I think encapsulates my fascination with this object, both the design and what it says about business.
但这并不是布兰诺克测量仪的宣传方式。对，对。我的意思是，它当然吸引了你的注意力，但它没有靠炒作。布兰诺克测量仪也吸引了我的注意力。关于布兰诺克测量仪公司，有一个故事我认为完美概括了我对这个物品的迷恋，无论是它的设计还是它所传达的商业哲学。
About 20 years ago, current Brannick president, Tim Follett, saw an opportunity. The discount chain, Payless Shoe Source, had started introducing foot measuring devices into their stores for the first time. Here's Tim. And they were considering the knockoffs. But these knockoffs weren't very good. They are poor quality. Matter of fact, some of them send, actually, they send a little screwdriver with them in an extra screw.
大约20年前，现任布兰诺克公司总裁蒂姆·福利特看到了一个商机。折扣连锁店“派乐鞋店”（Payless Shoe Source）开始首次在他们的门店里引入足部测量仪。以下是蒂姆的讲述。他们当时在考虑那些山寨货。但这些山寨货质量很差。事实上，其中一些甚至还会随货附送一个小螺丝刀和一颗额外的螺丝。
I don't know how you could be an owner of any establishment. And, you know, it's like getting your car with an extra transmission. And as a brand that relied on selling a large, volume of cheap shoes, Tim knew that Payless needed a device that would stand up to abuse. So I went to a local mall, and I took a bunch of brand new device, our brand new devices, and they actually had some knockoffs in the mall. So I traded with the manager. I took the old broken ones and gave him some of ours. Tim took those knockoff brandic devices home, figured out who at Payless headquarters was in charge of purchasing them, and sent him the broken
我不知道任何一家店的老板怎么会，你知道的，这就好比你买辆车，车里还多送你一个变速箱。作为一家依赖大量销售廉价鞋履的品牌，蒂姆深知派乐鞋店需要一种能够经受得住恶劣使用的设备。于是我去了当地的一家商场，带了一堆崭新的测量仪——我们崭新的测量仪，而且商场里确实有一些山寨货。所以我跟经理做了个交换。我拿走了那些旧的、坏掉的，然后给了他一些我们的产品。蒂姆把那些山寨的布兰诺克测量仪带回家，查出派乐鞋店总部负责采购的人是谁，然后把那些损坏的
devices. And I said, if you buy the knockoffs, this is what you're buying. And I said in five years, this is what your store is going to be filled with. And that reflects poorly on your store. It's like going into a restaurant, nice restaurant and having broken chairs. It worked. We ended up getting all the payless business for many, many years as an investment. But you won't find a brand device in a payless these days, because there are no payless stores anymore. Yeah, they went out of business. Payless went bankrupt in 2019 for a lot of reasons. Mall traffic had plummeted.
设备寄给了他。我对他说：“如果你买山寨货，这就是你买到的东西。”我说：“五年后，你们的店里就会塞满这种东西。”这会对你们店的声誉产生负面影响。这就好比你走进一家餐厅，一家不错的餐厅，里面却坐着坏掉的椅子。这招奏效了。作为一项投资，我们最终在很多很多年里拿下了派乐鞋店所有的业务。但如今你在派乐鞋店里已经找不到布兰诺克测量仪了，因为派乐鞋店已经不复存在了。是的，他们倒闭了。派乐鞋店于2019年申请破产，原因有很多。商场客流量暴跌。
They had a hard time competing with online companies like Zappos. But there's something else that contributed to the downfall of Payless, a trend that's been growing in the American financial system since the 1980s. Private equity. Here's where I'm going to go on a bit of a digression, but I assure you I'll eventually tie it back to the beautiful simplicity of the brandic device in the brand of device company. You may have heard private equity linked to the fight over Taylor Swift's Masters,
他们很难与Zappos这样的在线公司竞争。但还有别的原因导致了派乐鞋店的倒闭，这是自20世纪80年代以来在美国金融系统中不断滋生的一种趋势。私募股权。接下来我要稍微扯远一点，但我向你保证，我最终会把它跟布兰诺克测量仪及布兰诺克测量仪公司的美好简单性联系起来。你可能听说过私募股权与泰勒·斯威夫特版权之争的联系，
or you might remember that 2012 presidential candidate Mitt Romney had been the CEO of a private equity firm called Bain Capital, and private equity encompasses a lot of things. But what most people mean when they talk about it is something called a leveraged buyout. Here's the basic idea. A private equity firm identifies a company that they want to buy, and they get a sale price for that company. But the key here is that the private equity firm pays only a portion of that sale price, usually between 10 and 30%. The rest of the sale is covered by a loan from a bank. So in that way, it's kind of like a home mortgage, except with a leverage buyout, the company being
或者你可能记得2012年总统候选人米特·罗姆尼曾是一家名为“贝恩资本”的私募股权公司的首席执行官，私募股权涵盖了很多东西。但大多数人在谈论它时所指的是一种名为“杠杆收购”的东西。其基本思路如下：一家私募股权公司锁定了一家他们想要收购的公司，并商定了该公司的一个出售价格。但这里的关键在于，私募股权公司只支付该出售价格的一部分，通常在10%到30%之间。其余的收购资金由银行贷款支付。所以从某种意义上说，这有点像房屋抵押贷款，只不过在杠杆收购中，被收购的公司
bought is taking on the debt of a loan. They're the ones incurring the risk. Private equity firms pick companies they feel have steady revenue, but room for them. for improvement. The firm installs their own leadership to restructure the business, and the goal is to make the company stronger and to sell it again at a profit. But often, the restructuring means layoffs and other big cuts, and taking a company and settling them with a ton of debt right away can make these turnarounds really difficult, especially if the company is already struggling. Toys R Us, Joanne's Fabrics, Sports Authority, Radiocheck, all these companies and their employees are victims of leverage buyouts.
承担了贷款的债务。是他们在承担风险。私募股权公司挑选那些他们认为有稳定收入但仍有改进空间的民营企业。该公司会安插自己的管理层来重组业务，其目标是让公司变得更强大，然后再将其转手卖出以获取利润。但通常情况下，重组意味着裁员和其他大规模削减开支，而让一家公司背负巨额债务去进行收购，会使这些扭亏为盈的努力变得异常艰难，特别是如果该公司本身就已经举步维艰的话。玩具反斗城、Joanne's Fabrics、Sports Authority、RadioShack，所有这些公司及其员工都是杠杆收购的受害者。
And then there's Payless. In 2012, a group of private equity firms purchased Payless for $2 billion. They saw an opportunity to modernize a legacy chain. Payless was turning a profit under this new ownership, but that wasn't enough. Private equity firms want to make money for their investors, not just when they sell the company down the line, but they want to make money right away. So Payless had to pay dividends to their new shareholders, which ended up erasing all the profits they made. Any money that could have gone to their workers or passed along to the consumers in the form of better products or cheaper prices went straight to the investors.
然后就是派乐鞋店。2012年，一群私募股权公司以20亿美元的价格收购了派乐鞋店。他们看到了一个将老牌连锁企业现代化的机会。在这一新所有权下，派乐鞋店确实实现了盈利，但这还不够。私募股权公司希望为他们的投资者赚钱，不仅是在未来出售公司时赚钱，而且他们希望立刻赚钱。因此，派乐鞋店必须向其新股东支付股息，这最终抹去了他们赚取的所有利润。任何本可以用于支付给员工，或者以更好的产品或更便宜的价格回馈消费者的资金，全都直接进了投资者的口袋。
This was the beginning of the end for Payless. Payless filed for bankruptcy in 2019. They closed all their U.S. stores. They laid off thousands of workers in those stores and hundreds more in the company's cancel. as headquarters. Compare that to the Branick Device Company. You don't have to have a huge product on. You make this one thing. You specialize in it. You're good at it. You know, people know you for it. Your customers keep coming back to you for it. And it puts food on the table for you and your employees. The invention of the brandic device and the company's consistent production of a quality product that
这是派乐鞋店走向终结的开始。派乐鞋店于2019年申请破产。他们关闭了在美国的所有门店。他们解雇了这些门店里的数千名员工，以及公司总部里的数百名员工。相比之下，再看看布兰诺克测量仪公司。你不需要拥有庞大的产品线。你只制造这一样东西。你专精于它。你把它做好。你知道的，人们因此而记住你。你的顾客不断回购。它为你和你的员工提供了生计。布兰诺克测量仪的发明，以及该公司始终如一地生产出能够
could stand up to years of use and abuse in a shoe store and their commitment to making that product in the U.S. in Syracuse, New York, a commitment to so strong that it transcended the life of the founder Charles Branick. And even that they didn't sell to the highest bidder. You know, that they weren't just trying to milk this product or this estate, you know, for the highest price they could get. All these things represent an array of deeply held values, dare I say, American values. They aren't and never were exclusive to the U.S., but they are values at the center of the stories we like to tell about ourselves. That sort of worked. That vision or version of capitalism and manufacturing worked for a long time. And it's really not the economy we have now in America.
经受鞋店多年使用和虐待的高品质产品的承诺，他们致力于在美国本土——纽约州锡拉丘兹制造该产品的承诺——这种承诺如此强烈，以甚至超越了创始人查尔斯·布兰诺克的生命周期。甚至他们没有把公司卖给出价最高的人。你知道的，他们并没有试图榨取这个产品或这笔资产的最高售价。所有这些都代表了一系列根深蒂固的价值观，我敢说，这就是美国价值观。它们过去不是、现在也并非美国所独有，但它们正是我们喜欢讲述的关于我们自身的那些故事的核心价值观。这种运作方式。那种资本主义和制造业的愿景或版本曾长期奏效。但这真的不是我们今天在美国拥有的经济形态。
The modern American business doesn't have room for all these values. The value of quality, the value of taking care of workers, the value of community, the value of honoring the wishes of the founder. In the modern world of private equity, those have all been reduced to one value. Shareholder value. I think that is a loss. And it's one of the reasons why the 100-year existence of the brandic device company means something to me. And it makes me happy. And in 2026, they're doing okay. They still make three or 400 a week, they tell me. The company does say it's quite a few years ago now that they sold their millionth brannock device. So they're well past a million in terms of the lifetime of the product.
现代美国商业容不下所有这些价值观。品质的价值、关爱员工的价值、社区的价值、尊崇创始人愿望的价值。在私募股权的现代世界里，这些都被简化为一个单一的价值。股东价值。我认为这是一种损失。这也是布兰诺克测量仪公司存在了一百年对我而言意义重大的原因之一。这让我感到高兴。到了2026年，他们过得还不错。他们告诉我，他们现在每周仍然生产三四百个。该公司确实说过，几年前他们就卖出了他们的第100万个布兰诺克测量仪。所以在该产品的整个生命周期中，他们的销量早已突破百万。
I'm pretty surprised by that stat of a 400. a week. That's very impressive. I have to confess, I was a little surprised by that as well, and I found it heartening. So there is still a market out there, even with the knockoffs, and even with really the biggest challenge they've faced, is the decline in brick and mortar shoe stores and the decline in malls, because a lot of people don't go to the shoe store anymore to buy shoes or to have their kids buy shoes. They order on the internet. But in a nice, another one of these sort of parallel developments, just as shoe sales have moved from brick and mortar to the internet, brandic sales have also moved from the shoe store to the internet.
我对每周400个的这个统计数据感到相当惊讶。这非常令人印象深刻。我必须坦白，我自己也对这个数字感到有点惊讶，而且我发现这很令人鼓舞。所以市场上依然有需求，尽管有山寨货，尽管他们面临着真正最大的挑战——实体鞋店的衰落和商场的没落，因为许多人不再去鞋店买鞋或者给孩子买鞋了。他们是在网上订购。但在另一个有趣的平行发展中，就像鞋履销售从实体店转向互联网一样，布兰诺克测量仪的销售也从鞋店转向了互联网。
Yes, you can be like Paul and have your very own brandic device. And they say that direct to consumer sales are now part of their business. And that was something that was unheard of in Charlie Brannock's day. He was selling only wholesale to shoe stores. So that's an interesting thing that I like the thought that. You know, some people now have brand of devices in their home. And that's kind of a nice thing to see. I think it's nice, too.
是的，你可以像保罗一样，拥有属于你自己的布兰诺克测量仪。他们说面向消费者的直销现在已经是他们业务的一部分了。这在查理·布兰诺克的年代是闻所未闻的。他当时只向鞋店进行批发销售。所以这是一件很有趣的事情，我喜欢这种想法：你知道的，现在有些人家里也有了布兰诺克测量仪。看到这一点感觉挺好的。我也觉得挺好的。
This object essentially unchanged, without corporate backing, indoors, not because it changed with the times, but because it is still the best at what it does. And maybe it'll keep being the best, even after most of us are long gone. It'll be this exemplar of competency, as evidenced by a visionary director, George Miller. In the 2015 film Mad Max Fury Road, Furiosa's rig uses a brannock device as an improvised gas pedal. There are several close-up shots of the foot depressing this brannic device that powers the rig. And I thought that was kind of ingenious. It's so cool because it's a testament to the fact that these things are so well made and that they last through the apocalypse and will serve as the gas pedal.
这个物品基本保持不变，在没有企业资本支持的情况下延续至今，不是因为它随波逐流，而是因为它仍然是同类产品中最好的。也许它会继续保持最好，甚至在我们大多数人早已离去之后。它将成为能力的典范，正如远见卓识的导演乔治·米勒所证明的那样。在2015年的电影《疯狂的麦克斯：狂暴之路》中，弗瑞奥萨的重型卡车用了一个布兰诺克测量仪作为临时的油门踏板。电影中有好几个特写镜头，展示了脚踩下这个为卡车提供动力的布兰诺克测量仪。我当时觉得这真是个天才的想法。太酷了，因为这证明了这些东西是如此经久耐用，它们能在末日浩劫中幸存下来，并充当油门踏板。
Exactly. The indestructible brannic device, the thing that's going to, as you say, survive the apocalypse. Many thanks to Paul Lucas for knowing absolutely everything there is to know about the brannock device. You can find more of Paul's writing at inconspicuous.com. His logo is, of course, a brannic device. A history of the United States and 100 Objects is a production of 99% Invisible and BBC Studios. It's hosted and curated by me, Roman Mars. This episode was produced by Isabel Angel.
完全正确。坚不可摧的布兰诺克测量仪，正如你所说，它将历经末日而幸存。非常感谢保罗·卢卡斯，他了解关于布兰诺克测量仪的一切。你可以在inconspicuous.com上找到更多保罗的文章。他的标志当然就是布兰诺克测量仪。“100件物品中的美国史”是“99%隐形”与BBC工作室联合制作的节目。由我罗曼·马斯主持并策划。本集由伊莎贝尔·安杰尔制作。
Our series producers are Priscilla Al-Bee, Brenna Daldorf, and Ellie Lightfoot. Our associate producer is Isaac Fisher. This series was edited by Annie Brown and Courtney Harrell, mixing by Charlie Brandon King. Fact-checking by Amy Bracken. Our theme song is by Swan Real. From 99% Invisible, our executive producer is Kathy 2. From BBC studios, our executive producers are Annie Brown and Courtney Harrell. Our production coordinator is Shan Palais, and the production manager is Mabel Finnegan Wright, artwork by Stefan Lawrence.
我们的系列制作人是普里西拉·阿尔比、布伦娜·达尔多夫和埃利·莱特福特。我们的副制作人是艾萨克·费舍尔。本系列由安妮·布朗和考特尼·哈雷尔剪辑，查理·布兰登·金负责混音。艾米·布拉克森负责事实核查。我们的主题曲由斯旺·里尔创作。来自“99%隐形”，我们的执行制作人是凯茜·图。来自BBC工作室，我们的执行制作人是安妮·布朗和考特尼·哈雷尔。我们的制作统筹是尚·帕莱，制作经理是梅贝尔·芬尼根·赖特，美工由斯特凡·劳伦斯负责。
99% Invisible is part of the Serious XM podcast family, headquartered in Beautiful, Uptown, Oakland, California. And BBC Studios is headquartered in beautiful, White City, West London. If you want to get in touch or have an object for us to consider, email us at 100 Objects at 99PI.org. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
“99%隐形”是SiriusXM播客家族的一员，总部位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰美丽的住宅区。BBC工作室总部位于西伦敦美丽的白城。如果你想与我们联系，或者有考虑中的物品，请发送电子邮件至100Objects@99PI.org。谢谢。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。